[Music]
thank you for joining us for a walk
through of the quidd proquo marketplace
on the gajumaru
blockchain quidd proquo is a platform
for enabling trade between people and
businesses without the burden of
controlling
profit seeking
intermediation quidd pro quo is a world
first an onchain Marketplace that uses
Dynamic smart contracts between
counterparties to govern their
transaction rather than relying upon
intermediation by a third
party the gajim Maru is a new blockchain
that has been built with the express
purpose of creating a unifying resource
layer that allows blockchain technology
to reach its potential as an economic
Transformer to do that IT addresses four
critical missing elements that have left
the existing blockchain protocols as
fractured islands with high friction
connections between them that invite
Domination by intermediaries precisely
what blockchain was supposed to remove
our dependency
upon the first of these is Groot the
core of the
gajumaru everything you will see in this
walk through is uniquely made possible
by the gajumaru and is running on this
core base
Network Groot is a nonc corruptible
censorship resistant open source proof
of work blockchain protocol that
provides programmatic consensus for all
operations open to all controlled by
none a critical feature for a global
resource layer Groot is extremely fast
very lowc cost trustless in
operation a fully fledged blockchain in
its own right capable of handing any
transaction handed to it we can now
truly say that we can trust the message
rather than the messenger securely at
scale however groots true purpose is
twofold the first is to Mint the gaju
the native currency of the gaju Maru
which we will come to next the second
purpose and the answer to why this is a
resource for the whole world is to
enable complete Network interoperability
and facilitate value transfers amongst
the universe of blockchains that it
makes possible the backbone for global
economic infrastructure to work
next we have the gaju the gaju is a non
debas non-c corruptible censorship
resistant
cryptocurrency that establishes a common
native currency for the gajim Maru it
does so by implementing the Bitcoin Next
Generation
protocol gaju is a currency that
delivers high-speed secure efficient
value transfer in real world use as we
are about to
think Bitcoin evolved or more correctly
Bitcoin Next
Generation thousands of times faster and
more efficient everything that Bitcoin
once promised to be made real real money
that is money based upon a finite
resource that can be proven whose
extraction has value for example gold or
a cryptographic puzzle not to
not sensable tradable between peers
without intermediation as this
demonstration will
show thirdly we have customizable
interoperable infrastructure that we
call associate chains linking to the
core Groot associate chains operate
independently while interacting through
this shared resource layer allowing
specific needs to be met by specific
infrastructural Solutions including
including National and Regulatory
boundaries associate chains are not a
layer to they are aware of Groot and
Groot is aware of them the object of
Groot is not to validate their operation
but to facilitate their operation with
one
another as composable infrastructure
they allow solutions to be customized to
requirements rather than the current
blockchain practice of shoehorning
requirements to prescriptive
Solutions this also allows something
like quid proquo to grow and
evolve quid proquo May well evolve far
beyond the capabilities of Gro and
require its own associate chain to
function as effectively as possible
whilst remaining natively interconnected
with the rest of the network through the
core indeed it may require multiple
associate chains within that associate
chain to facilitate National systems and
varying regulatory boundaries for
trade in fact so important is this
aspect it is why we named the blockchain
the gajumaru the gajumaru is a Japanese
tree that grows in the same way that our
blockchain grows there is a core that
enables a universe of infrastructure to
evolve organically from it fully mature
a single gajim Maru resembles a forest
an excellent metaphor for our
solution finally but by no means least
we have utilized Sophia and fate Sophia
is the secure Enterprise friendly native
smart contract language utilizing
efficient fate virtual
machines both designed by worldclass
Engineers of global
repute these provide the operating tools
for the entire system we will see these
in action during this
walkthrough ethereum and its core
Innovation solidity was a great proof of
concept for smart contracts but its
inadequacies are irreparable and its use
by Enterprise or government
dangerous Sophia resolved these issues
whilst retaining adoptability by python
trained Engineers removing another
bottleneck the number of people
conversent in the language of smart
contracts now that we have covered how
the quidd proquo marketplace can operate
at all we can move on to looking at the
walkthrough and the demonstration of its
utility we start with Alice a goat soap
producer from El
Salvador she plans to sell her goat soap
on the quidd proquo marketplace to the
world Alice has a gajumaru wallet with
multiple accounts Alice can see her
total balance of 2,000 gajus she selects
the account she wants to use with the
quidd pro quo
Marketplace to log in to quidd pro quo
Alice only needs her gaju Maru wallet no
site account is required this is thanks
to grids a universal secure login
mechanism that removes the need for
third parties what does that mean well
imagine logging into a website you have
never been to before without a username
password or any private data exposed to
the site as a website provider imagine
not needing to comply with
gdpr the login action provides a QR code
and a grids URL for external wallet
authentication fast easy
secure grids is fundamental to the
internet of Economics establishing a
distinct transactional protocol from the
internet of data where we find the
information that leads to our
transactional choices your data is now
yours your assets can now be yours your
money gaju can also now be
yours in this case Alice is using our
desktop wallet
clutch she simply copies and pastes the
URL directly into her wallet using the
Grid's URL Link in the wallet using our
Mobile Wallet our Bor on a smartphone
Alice would scan the QR code and have
the same effect opening her wallet for
her the wallet reads the URL and
translates it into a retrieval
instruction
the wallet retrieves a random message
from quidd Pro quo's backend asking
Alice to sign it to prove her identity
Alice signs the message and the
signature is verified by quid proquo
confirming her
identity when Alice clicked okay the
message was signed and the signature was
submitted to the quidd proquo system
which then verified that she owns the
public key that was presented Alice is
now securely logged into the
marketplace Alice is a new user so quid
proquo creates a new user profile for
her to
complete Alice customizes her profile to
help her sell her wees thanks to grids
she always has secure access to her
account without needing any logins or
passwords Alice's profile is ready she
is ready to start selling her goods or
services in this case the goat soap that
she produces she clicks the cell button
to proceed to initiate a
sale the sale item creation page is
simple to use and navigate Alice
produces goat milk soap and provides a
detailed description of what she is
selling with keywords to Aid searches so
that buyers looking for specialist soaps
will find her
offer she sets a price here of
22.95 gadus per item in future she will
also be able to create an auction
listing Alice fills in the details for
the item she wants to sell and submits
it to the
system the backend system optimizes and
sanitizes the images she has provided
taking a few moments to process them
once they are processed they will appear
but Alice can continue to move through
the steps to listing her
sale the system processes the images and
the offering is now ready for Alice to
make to do this she must first post the
sale contract to the gajumaru blockchain
and await site administrator
approval this moderation function is the
only external function in the system
there to ensure this is no Silk Road but
instead the basis for a future economy
of goods and services on
chain posting the sale contract to the
gajim Maru blockchain requires a
contract call to the chain which the
quidd pro quo backend has formed for
Alice to
sign Alice is therefore taken to another
grids page this time with a contract
call in its contents instead of a log
message this is the first step in the
creation of the smart contract that will
govern the transaction between the
parties removing the need for thirdparty
intermediation and greatly reducing the
cost to suppliers relative to using
services like Amazon eBay Etsy or
Shopify the transaction data is now in
Alice's wallet awaiting her approval to
sign and submit back to the quidd proquo
platform once submitted we immediately
see that the sale item changes status to
open and provides a unique contract ID
the address of the sale contract onchain
the system has paused the transaction
for moderator approval as indicated at
the top Alice's user page shows her
unreviewed sale item a goat milk soap
bar set for 22 .95
gashu now we switch to the quidd pro quo
moderator screen we see it showing
Alice's unreviewed sale item in the
queue for
review switching back to Alice's view we
can see the approved message and that
the item is now live on the site and
available for
purchase enter Bob also known as Robert
the stinky who needs some soap that
won't hurt his sensitive skin you'll
note that we see his wallet on the right
hand side of this
screen Bob's search for goat soap as a
cure for his sensitive skin leads him to
Alice's wonderful goat soaps at
22.95 gajus they seem to be a great
price to Bob who decides to buy
some at the bottom of the screen there
is a big friendly by button Bob clicks
on this to initiate the
transaction bidding on an item requires
Bob to place money from his account into
his sale account on the gajumaru
blockchain gajumaru wallets operate in
the secure Enclave of your device so the
money cannot be received by the seller
until the two have agreed to the sale
completed negotiating the smart contract
between them and reached a final binding
agreement
Bob's wallet tells him the details of
the transaction and he can check that
the transaction data that his wallet
picked up is the same as what he is
shown on the
site once the bid is submitted and
processed by the chain the status of the
sale changes from open to nego short for
negotiation if Bob has some concern
about the item its price the shipping
terms or anything else he can place the
sale on hold at any time in this case
for Alice and Bob to transact a logistic
solution will be required to deliver the
soap from Alice to Bob this action is
enforced on Chain by the sale contract
itself here we see that Bob is in
Australia and the seller Alice is
shipping from El
Salvador Alice looks up the shipping
cost an additional 10 gaju and adjusts
the price to to include shipping in the
final price to
32.9550 of quid pro quo's backend
systems and services will permit
integrated automated Customs compliance
for now the process relies upon manual
conventions as we see here as the price
update is governed by the contract on
chain the update to
32.9550 gashu and Bob's original bid is
still in the contract but is now
insufficient for the
sale Bob now needs to click update bid
to generate a contract call that will
supply the additional 10 gajus from his
wallet the site makes Bob aware of the
required transaction once complete we
can see the accept bid option appear on
Alice's
screen now Bob has updated his bid to
cover the 10 gaju logistical cost Alice
can accept his bid and finalize the
transaction the transaction between the
two is entirely created by the inputs of
the parties and the quidd pro quo system
using the gajumaru sopia smart contract
language this next step requires a final
contract call it is at this point that
Alice gets paid the 32.9550
is important to Aid people in making
judgments on whom to trade
with just as in the physical world
reputation matters and honest appraisal
by genuine buyers of a good or service
are a vital tool in building that
reputation ultimately many retail
businesses depend upon this and this
intangible asset also known as Goodwill
is what makes a business worth more than
some of its parts once Bob submits his
review the sale item including images
conversation history and so on is
deleted and the history of the sale
becomes an archive record that keeps
some important metadata about the sale
users of the site have a sale archive
and purchase history which keeps track
of their purchase and sale Behavior so
that others can make vital trust
decisions with that we conclude our
demonstration thank you very much for
watching we hope that this has inspired
you blockchain changes our world from
being about control to facilitation and
adding value to a common open
hole that is what quidd proquo is all
about and we invite you to join with us
if you would like to know more please
get in touch via the qpq website qq.com
Swiss or any of our social media contact
points we'd love to hear from you thank
you
[Music]